zach shay aka zhc is a comic artist
known for his custom paintings on homes
and schools and hospitals to spread joy
to those who need it and he doesn't stop
there
his youtube channel has over wow 22
million subscribers
hi drew this is zach i am behind your
stage right now please don't hate me but
i stole one of your air fryers it's it's
very pretty and i'm going to paint it
for you
if i mess this up i hope there are more
air fryers i can start on all right
here goes nothing
i actually did mess up
uh
is there any way to get this off
because i think we were talking about
drawing and i instead of d r
e i wrote d-r-a
[Music]
oops i messed up again
[Music]
okay i think i am all done with this so
over here i heard she likes yellow and
honey and flowers and stuff so so i drew
my character honey and he is eating
uh honey off of this this drew honeycomb
thing they're having a good time here on
top i i just put air because because
it's an air fryer so it's a no oil hope
you like it drew
i'm so excited
that's the exact one i have in my
kitchen and it is getting replaced today
are you kidding me the girls are gonna
freak out thank you zac you like it it's
so awesome
i
love this
[Music]